The female body, amazing in its own way, not as strong or as fast as the male body...
...but it still works for cooking, cleaning and collecting firewood.
The female's brain is about the same size as the male brain...
...but it is not equipped with the math skills needed...
...to beat world records or keep score,...
...which is why women use calculators.
From a psychological view, the female mind is conditioned from an early age...
...to know her place.
A lack of female athletes and coaches helps reinforce this conditioning.
Their weak minds match their weak bodies so more sports scholarships are given to boys.
Women are ruled by hormones, which is why they sometimes gather and try to play games.
And although they have the same sweat glands as their male counterparts,...
...their glands should never actually produce sweat.
The female body is built to have babies, lots and lots of babies.
So every month, girls experience their menstrual cycle.
At this time, they must be kept inside lest they attract bears.
Giving girls their own playing fields is potentially deadly and should be avoided.
Even riding a bike might cause feminine damage.
For her own protection, she should walk but never alone or at night.
So as you can see, the female body is most efficient at rest.
Any rigorous physical activity might cause breakage,...
...internal bleeding or long bouts of crying,...
...which is why women should never play sports.
That's biology folks!
There's nothing we can do about it.
Beat the inequality, stereotypes, unfair pay, myths, mistreatment, absurdity, stupidity.
Beat the BS.